a great marshal for today's races one
white going from the Blue Collar Comedy
Tour old tater salad Jordans here for a
few moments how you doing
there's having a great time and really
appreciate the folks over at Aaron's
we're at a tea if not only meeting my
wife consecutive national Hannah Parker
ray and killed it again so it's a great
day we have somebody friends that are
out there grabbing right now and it
makes it look like they're you've done
some acting as well you're in a horrible
faucet us and nine sex of the city to
which I think was very well cast but the
thing with people think of sex that tell
us about this Jayne Mansfield car well
hoppers real quick for this race back to
be over this call is Jane Manzo stars
have made better by forward Robert
Duvall John heard Robert Patrick Kevin
Bacon it's a dark comedy and it's so
dark nothing funny happens in the whole
moon
sheer uncomfortableness and I think it's
gonna be a great feeling probably have
to fall I'm not in the loop so they
don't know what's been happening right
now become
thank you guys
there is a race going on out here let's
get back to it
that kid in one Dan are rotten thank you
for coming up
good to see here tell me thanks for
happy on your radio show I appreciate it
never see you again